can we go back to your script reading
days first off what qualifies someone
as a script reader like how do you how
do they know you're ready to be doing
coverage
it's so funny nothing nothing qualified
me at all
um i got the job and they started
shoving scripts in my hand i had no
qualifications for that whatsoever
and that's the truth i got better as i
went like i'm sure my first synopsis was
kind of like what the hell is this
but i'm doing three a day so eventually
i'm getting better and better and better
and that's the thing too like nothing
nothing qualifies you in this industry
like if you want to make films if you
want to
act whatever you want to do there's no
qualification people were like
it's not like every other job and so
but at the same time the problem is the
whole world doesn't
it is the same when it comes to
experience
that's the difference it's not the same
as a qualification as
oh i went to harvard um oh of course
you're qualified to do this job or not
and it's more about oh you've done 15
movies i've seen you have the the
qualifications in the way that i put a
camera on you and you're not going to
get nervous
you know what i mean you're going to
deliver and all that kind of stuff
it's very different in that way and
really
the people i see succeed um are the
people that never give up and keep
keep learning and getting better and
better and better and and it's very rare
to see that because
certain people get to a certain age and
they want to have babies they want to do
certain things
and certain things are pulling them in
different directions
and you know it's very hard to keep
trying to do the same thing if you
haven't hit the
ideal of what you you know imagine
but a lot of people come here and say
i'll give it a year like i said before
but it's like would you if you wanted to
be the ceo of apple would you give it a
year
or w because that's what this is if
you're like the lead in the tv show
you're a ceo of that company now you're
the face of that tv show
everyone is putting millions of dollars
behind you
so you better be good really good you
know and have
no work your way up and and and you know
be the ceo of that company because
that's what you are at that point so
that's
you know and the same thing with the
director in a movie like if you
they give you 20 or 40 million dollars
or 100 million dollars to make a movie
i mean the money speaks for itself
you're a ceo of that company
you're completely in charge of making
that a good movie or a bad movie at that
point
so it takes time to get that good
and to get people to believe in you you
know so you didn't have
like sort of the qualifications that you
thought you would have had to
have been a script reader or you were
just surprised that they entrusted you
um it was it was mind-blowing to me
because before that point we would
uh me and my brother were writing
scripts back in oregon when i had no
connections whatsoever and we would
meet a guy that could get it to somebody
else i was now on the other side of it
all
reading the scripts and i realized when
i was writing them they were handing it
to the intern that has absolutely no
qualifications it might just
not like my script no you mostly
everyone reading a script has no
qualifications whatsoever
they read it and then if they like it
because of their opinion
it goes up the ladder with someone else
who has more experience someone else has
more experience and eventually maybe
someone who
really can look at a script and dissect
the whole thing
but you have to get through all these
other layers of people that
really don't know what they're doing so
you better it better be so good that
they read it
uh and are just so intrigued by it but
it also can just be
you ran into the right people the right
three people that loved your script or
loved your idea or whatever so no mostly
everyone reading a script has no
qualifications in the beginning at a
studio so the bottom layer people have
no qualifications
and so would you ever stop reading a
script or you had
your job was to read it all the way
through
you're doing three scripts a day so i
mean if i read and it's just horrible
the first 20 pages
i'm going to try to sum up the the
script the best way possible i'll go
read the last
15 pages and most of the people in the
office would tell me that they say
like um somebody in there i remember was
like just read the first 10 and the last
decide if you like it and then you might
read it but otherwise
that's all that matters like if it's not
good there like get rid of it you know
so yeah so i ended up doing that
sometimes and i felt bad for people you
know but if it was bad it was bad
you know i mean that's the thing like
when you have a stack next to you
there's 20 scripts am i really gonna
not everyone's gonna get an opportunity
so if your first 20 pages
there's no bad the whole thing has to be
amazing so the first 20 pages are bad
well then your script's done it's not
going to get to the next level
so and actually now that i've made a
film distribution companies tell me like
that first 10 minutes of your movie
better be amazing like because people
will turn it off on these streaming
platforms
so you better put a lot of your budget
in that first 10 minutes have a chase
scene have a gun scene have
whatever captures them high drama you
know something to
drag that audience in and capture them
you know because everybody's attention
span is so
short nowadays so yeah and then what was
coverage like
if if you even if it was just the first
10 and the last 10
how much like what are you filling up on
a piece of paper of coverage what was it
like so i wouldn't actually write on the
script i would just write a one-page
synopsis
and try to basically make an outline of
the script
um really if you did coverage on your
own script you'd be saving people a lot
of time
to be honest with you because hollywood
people want your movie in one sentence
and then if they're intrigued by the one
sentence they'll want to read a
paragraph
so if you write one sentence that sums
up your movie great
then write a paragraph that sums up your
movie great then have a one-page
synopsis that
sums up your movie better and then have
the script and if you handed that to
somebody
they would love you to death because and
you can master getting each one of those
great because otherwise
the intern is going to run write your
one page synopsis when you could have
done it yourself in a way
or your one line or your one paragraph
or whatever
so that's kind of how it is and so then
you got the hangover it landed on your
desk or someone else they already loved
hangover i didn't i didn't greenlight
hangover they already had hangover they
liked hangover
um that was one of the two scripts that
they were developing at the time and
they were like it was that and another
script called manwich
and when they were like these are our
two movies that we're going to make
check them out eventually but at the
time
all the excitement was over the manwich
movie not over the hangover
and that was the next movie they're
gonna make next not hangover and i was
constantly like
and maybe todd always knew he's gonna do
hangover i don't know i wasn't really
talking to todd that much i mean he came
in the office
and once in a blue moon you know um
scott butnick
was his partner at the time and so i had
a lot more interaction with him
and for me when i read it it was just
you know it was very funny and it was it
was a page turner because it's a murder
mystery they're trying to find their
friend
so it was all solid it was good and
someone else actually wrote that script
and then todd and his partner rewrote
that script so
they didn't actually write the first
draft of it so um
and they went on i think to do some
other movies and stuff but yeah
so then eventually you saw that you
could become that guy or that girl and
you'd be making a nice living but
you wouldn't be doing exactly what you
wanted to do did you plan
to get out or was it one day where you
just threw a bunch of papers up in the
air and walked out
what happened no no um i mean i was only
at each place for like three months
anyway and both of the places
i mean both places it was
it was kind of a short-term thing anyway
so it wasn't like i had to go oh i'm
leaving it was kind of like well
the time is up that you were supposed to
be here anyway so that was nice in a way
it didn't
i didn't get promoted you know i mean
like oh yeah it's very hard for people
to turn down money when you first get
here so a lot of these people
it was like oh now i'm at fifty thousand
oh now i got a hundred thousand now i
got two hundred thousand i'm making 300
000 a year
i have a wife how am i supposed to leave
this job you know what i mean
you're money dependent on that job and
i'm lucky they didn't offer me a
position because i might have
tried to embrace it you know which a lot
of people do embrace
their nine to five jobs and give up on
their dreams
and um i'm lucky that i was raised by
my father and my mom and my dad always
instilled in me you can do anything you
want to do you just have to
go for it and not take no for an answer
so that's
that's kind of my mentality with life
you got to go do it
did you see that in him did he do it and
my dad my dad
actually was a musician back in the day
and uh
he uh he was almost the lead singer of
aerosmith when aerosmith like
was having drug problems and stuff and
there was a guy named arthur mann
basically that
put a contract in front of my dad and
was like i want you to perform in every
club bar stage from here to china
um and uh my dad
had unfortunately him my my mom was
pregnant at the time and he was
he decided to and he had a real job and
so he gave it up and he became a family
man really
and the the same contract arthur mann
gave it to
bon jovi so bon jovi ended up becoming
bon jovi and my dad ended up
being a dad and uh and shortly after
unfortunately my dad got in a bed car
accident and so he ended up being a
stay-home dad and my mom worked
and so my house was very reversed i
guess in the 80s
more people the mom stayed home and my
dad was the stamp dad so
it was very different in that way and
kind of crazy though because
he trained my sister how to sing and so
my sister is easy ward she's a big time
singer
and so you know the next generation
still made it as a singer she's signed
to hollywood records which is disney
and she's working on her third album now
so
um it kind of he passed up his music
dream but she accomplished it so it's
kind of nice to see that
full circle for him you know so
you